la situation de la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre est alarmante au québec des
secteurs entiers sont fragilisés à une
semaine de la mise à jour économique du
ministre eric girard l'institut du
québec propose un plan pour transformer
l'urgence en opportunité il ya aussi et
pdg de l'institut du québec bonsoir me
m6 ben ça alors comment vous qualifier
d'abord l'engagement du gouvernement
legault dans la gestion de ce qui
ressemble quand même de plus en plus à
une crise de la main d'oeuvre ben
justement on gère sa commune crise donc
avec des solutions pour éteindre des
feux un peu plus à court terme on l'a vu
beaucoup dans le système de santé avec
les préposés aux bénéficiaires les
éducatrices en garderie en cpe dans le
milieu de l'enseignement tout ça mais
c'est correct je pense que c'est
inévitable mais il fallait le faire ça a
été efficace les mesures ont été
efficaces mais il faut pas penser qu'on
va pouvoir gérer risques s'en vient qui
va durer une décennie avec juste des
mesures aussi ponctuel est vraiment une
réflexion de fond qui doit être fait et
on espère vraiment que la mise à jour et
qui s'en vient la semaine prochaine voit
une opportunité de revoir un peu cette
façon-là d'agir vous avez préparé un
graphique qui nous montre le taux de
postes vacants qui grandit plus
rapidement au québec c'est la ligne
bleue qu'en ontario la ligne rouge et ça
depuis 2000 15 exactement ces graphiques
lot intéressant parce que il nous montre
deux choses d'abord quand les données
ont commencé à être compilées en 2015 le
taux de postes vacants vacant au québec
étaient autour de 2% il était autour de
3 pour cent en ontario donc été
inférieur mais en 2018 il ya comme un
changement de tendance une inversion est
là le québec une augmentation de plus en
plus rapide des postes vacants donc non
seulement la situation a changé mais
c'est que ça s'est fait rapidement ici
pour ce que nos entreprises puis tous
les employeurs au québec incluant ce
service les services publics pour nous
les réseaux publics souffrent en ce
moment parce qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
de s'y ajuster et l'ap endives la
pandémie est venu empirer les choses
donc c'est tellement rapide qu'on a pas
le temps de s'adapter il ya des causes
structurelles à tout cela
principalement le vieillissement de la
population
exactement je pense qu'il faut vraiment
regarder les causes de deux façons les
causes fondamentales les structures elle
donc les tendances lourdes qui étaient
là avant qu'ils vont perdurer au delà de
la pandémie et le vieillissement de la
population c'est évident le changement
de l'économie donc le vient une virage
numérique en cours que c'est beaucoup
accéléré que change le profil des
compétences des travailleurs ceux ci ça
va être majeur au cours des prochaines
années et ensuite la population ce
vieillissement l'on sait que ça parte
pas demain matin alors il faut s'y faire
faut pas penser qu'il ya des solutions
magiques miracle qu'on va pouvoir avoir
maintenant qu'ils vont régler ça on est
dedans c'est irréversible comme tendance
ça c'est structurel êtes fous minium si
il ya des facteurs conjoncturels en
fonction de ce qui se passe présentement
notamment la paix c'est la pcu la pcr
eux les aides financières du des
gouvernements bon toulon ses demandes
pour que sont les travailleurs ou est-ce
qu'ils sont passés les gens une femme
qu'ils étaient là en 2018 2019 mais en
fait ils avaient déjà commencé à être
moins là mais avec la pandémie
évidemment il ya eu des mesures de
soutien aux revenus qui était fait dans
certains cas pour les travailleurs à
faible revenu et surtout à temps partiel
les fois plus élevé que le revenu qui
savait avant il ya des gens qui sont
retournés aux études qui ont décidé de
changer de secteur et aussi les
frontières ont été fermées donc d'une
année à l'autre en 2019 et 2020 on est
passé de 93 mille personnes qui étaient
soit des immigrants permanents ou
temporaires à onze mille mercis source
d'un choc énorme pour les entreprises
oui c'est quand même pas rien pu
beaucoup d'incertitudes aussi les
changements de plans les ouvertures les
rayer les fermetures également de
l'économie mais c'est sur pied un
secteur comme la restauration
l'hébergement ou qui ferment qui ouvre
qui en fou fermes ouvrent mais c'est
colossal parce que là d'un coup ils
doivent réembaucher tout le monde donc
c'est sûr que ça fait bondir les postes
vacants sa toile explique recrutement et
beaucoup de gens ont changé de secteur
ceux qui ont décidé qu'ils veulent plus
travailler le soir la fin de semaine et
retourneront probablement pas donc vous
avez trois recommandations pour le
ministre girard d'abord et avant tout de
développer une vision cohérente dites
vous des enjeux de main d'oeuvre bon
c'est exactement les pointes début
poitan défunt pie pas penser que les
migrants parce que les employeurs
demandent beaucoup plus d'immigrantes
temporaire permanent et où ni les
personnes de 60 ans et plus qui pour la
majorité ont quitté
marché du travail ça va pas être si
simple de les ramener donc il faut pas
compter sur ses segments au club pour
nous sauver il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin que ça peut avoir une vision
intégrée et globale ça veut dire pour
garder faut faire des prévisions faut
voir où vont être les plus grandes
tensions les plus grands besoins par
rapport aux services essentiels par
rapport aux secteurs de notre économie
qu'on veut développer l'on entendait le
premier ministre parler d'innovation des
colorations d'accord la construction on
investit massivement on veut développer
l'électrification des transports il faut
que le gouvernement pense à ces
ressources là à la formation des gens
donc c'est pas à la pièce c'est très
globale comme plan l'organisation du
travail ou si c'est majeur ça fait
partie du jeu résume donc vos trois
recommandations vision cohérente des
enjeux de main d'oeuvre le développement
économique qui doit être basée sur les
talents éducation formation et
développement des compétences
donc on verra mieux comme si ce qui va
rester de tout cela la mise à jour
économique et la semaine prochaine
présenté par le ministre eric girard
jeudi prochain merci pour cette analyse
ce soir merci à vous pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit